let's jump to the story from Politico
DeSantis says he won't get involved with
Trump's potential indictment in any way
right now on Twitter
it's heating up I'm seeing uh you know
Ben Shapiro he's quote tweeting Matt
Walsh internal riff at the daily wire
over whether or not Rhonda Santos could
should or would extradite Donald Trump
now it seems based on questions asked to
Defenders himself he's not going to get
involved in the indictment in any way
which sounds like he's saying outright I
will not extradite Donald Trump from
Mar-A-Lago to New York but
what happens to a country when a state
indicts a former president for the first
time in history who's also the current
front-runner
then the state that where he is says I
am not going to get involved he's not
getting extradited what do they do send
in the FBI to go extra item why would
the FBI do it I don't know I read
somewhere that the Secret Service is
supposed to be the one in charge of this
like they're sent out to arrest exactly
so the Secret Service will act upon a
state warrant that doesn't seem to make
sense to me no none of it makes sense
yeah no I think if if you want to say
we're living in a simulation in the
computer type way that it feels like AI
is writing all of this yeah which GPI is
writing all of this trumpets we're
trying something new this is crazy this
is this is new you know I looked into it
um and a lot of times like the only time
that maybe a governor won't give someone
over might be like for death penalty
let's say and and they don't they one
state believes in it one another state
doesn't
um never for really something like this
obviously where it's a felony of guilty
or uh more likely you know this is more
of a misdemeanor but they're going after
a felony but it also gets just wrapped
up in the courts within the state the
problem is if DeSantis says he won't get
involved and he commits to that and this
is actually happening that he will he
will absolutely not uh not become
president of the United States whenever
he he wants that base to to support him
that Trump basis he needs that Trump
base it's not just about the Trump base
it would be an utmost sign of weakness
and a failure of leadership if he allows
Trump to be arrested also within his
speech that he's talking about uh you
know not getting involved he's saying
that it's political persecution
okay so if you're saying it and you're
admitting to it but you're also at the
same time saying you're not going to do
anything about it this is how you be a
leader like you're saying exactly
teleporters happy like Jeb Bush you know
right Jeb Bush would like this rhetoric
from DeSantis yes that's why he has Jeb
Bush in his corner it's not even sure
it's it's it's already bad enough
DeSantis wasn't strong enough in his in
his statement saying I'm not going to
get involved in any way is already bad
enough if he actually lets Trump be
extraded so here's what needs to happen
DeSantis if he wants to prove he's
presidential he says Donald Trump he he
needs to come out and say Donald Trump
will not be extradited from this state
under my watch for a political
persecution he is the front-runner for
the Republican party's 2024 presidential
run he is a former president and
everyone can see these charges are
political if you make any attempt to
come into my state I will use the full
force of the executive branch to stop
you that is presidential yeah but he's
not doing that he goes I'm not going to
get involved yeah and a lot of people
say like oh well Trump's been taking
Jabs at him I totally understand that I
totally get it but if you do have if you
are looking to run for president either
2024 or the session after you know if
you want to be a leader lead like what
you're saying I mean lead the way
everyone's people are saying oh well
he's just a governor for for Florida
what other what other Governors are
saying anything well nobody's a governor
that's in the position that DeSantis is
in what are they so scared of what is
everyone so scared of ask yourself this
question right now and I mean this with
the utmost sincerity what are you scared
of why didn't you jump out of that plane
when you went skydiving the first time
when you were there with your friends
and they opened the door and then you
changed your mind the last minute and
rode the plane back down and said I just
couldn't do it why didn't you go down
that double black diamond with your
friends when they went skiing what are
you scared of now in those circumstances
I get it what if my parachute fails what
if what if I go too fast I crash I break
my bones that I get for Ron DeSantis for
a political position what are you so
scared of what is anyone scared of when
it comes to standing up well what if
some bad thing happens bad things are
already happening they're talking about
indicting a former president for the
first time on what we know is complete
BS charges well past the statute of
limitations to try and stop him in any
way they can from being president
because he's winning
what does Ron DeSantis fear by just
getting on camera looking straight into
it and saying Alvin Bragg go
yourself what is he so scared of I'm I'm
sorry I'm just frustrated because I am
absolutely sick in every capacity so
much of everyone being scared of
nebulous political consequences I
certainly don't give a and I'm
thinking to myself the last thing I'd
ever want to do is be in political
office but the more I see people even
like DeSantis refuse to say to the
camera in the Press y'all can go
yourselves then I'm just like we need
someone who's going to do it now I
really do get why Trump won in 2016. now
I really do get why I gained 12 million
voters and now I totally understand why
so many more people wear his hats fly
his flag because it's about time
somebody just said I don't care you
I'm doing it I think now you guys I
think it's because DeSantis is trying to
Pander to like the old school politics
and he's trying to be the the Trump
anti-trump figure but we're in a
post-trump post covid world where
everything's upside down everything's
insane and chaotic but he's like this
very politically vague statement is
pre-covered pre-trump and it's not going
to go anywhere I don't know who's trying
to keep happy with that kind of stuff
and he's doing a fantastic job within a
state I mean he really is but we're
talking about the fall of the nation
that's at risk here we're talking about
political persecution I mean hell how
many months ago did the Biden
Administration literally create a
Ministry of freaking truth things are
ten times worse now you need to buckle
up you need to lead because we're trying
to save the country from literally
becoming an all-out Banana Republic it's
also we have data we didn't have before
we understand ESG and the
military-industrial complex and the
world you know the new world order that
the Swiss banks the world economic
performance trying to create we
understand how the CCP is influencing
social governance like we know so we see
what we want to avoid and I think that
it gives us an opportunity to create the
world in the American Image with like
decentralized autonomy and local
governance and property rights and gun
rights and speed and things like that if
we do nothing in bicker they're going to
create some autocracy where you get
kicked off the internet you get your
bank Stripped Away because you said
Daddy wrong like that's what they're
scared of yeah you know and I think
about it like the reason Ron DeSantis
gave the answer he gave which was like
okay a lot of people were cheering for
it some people rolled their eyes I don't
think it was strong enough better than
him saying well you know if they want to
arrest him they're going to have to
extradine them and I guess that'll
happen but it wasn't a very strong
statement you know what he's worried
about he's worried about his polling
numbers he's worried about when he runs
for the president eventually announcing
and then resigning or whatever as he
does he's worried that it's going to
look bad to a certain voter base
Suburban women are getting angry and say
oh he's so aggressive and abusive and
it's just like look man
he doesn't need to literally come out
and say go f yourself to Elven Bragg
it was not bad that he it was really
good actually he ragged on the Soros D.A
he says they're evil people destroying
things I give him total respect for that
because that is good that was the best
part of the speech I'm just saying like
he needs to come out and just outright
say there will not be an extradition of
Donald Trump while I am governor of
Florida mark my words you will and then
you know what I'd love to see you want
to know what really make him
presidential if when Secret Service
whoever does show up to Mar-A-Lago Ronda
sandus himself stands in front of the
door and says make me you'll have to
move me physically the governor of this
state make that happen I dare you that'd
be gangster then people are going to be
like damn yeah that would be that would
be but he's not going to do it a real
and I like DeSantis he's doing a great
job over here
you know I got it best even Trump
wouldn't do something like that yeah he
said he's not going to get involved
quotes uh or whatever so how does this
work extradition does it go through the
governor where the governor say yes or
no or does it happen completely separate
of the governor only the governor can
step in and stop it I'm I'm a to the
best of my understanding it's not
necessarily up to the governor obviously
they can come out and be the face of the
position of the state but I believe it
has to do with you know the courts
within the state but not so much like
the government the governor just says
yes and and or or no and that's what it
is I don't believe it indicates he's
going to let him get extradited and he's
not going to step in to stop it because
if his if it's his job to do it and he
says I'm not getting involved that
indicates he's not going to do it but if
his job is all he can do really is stop
it from happening he says not get
involved then he's not going to stop it
from happening even if he was just like
politically posturing and and making it
be known even if he didn't have control
even if he said something like what
Tim's saying that would help you know
what he's doing right now is the exact
opposite you know who would do exactly
what I just said Kerry Lake yep yeah I
was thinking Carrie like 100 she told
100 100 and you knew it you you said it
right away no questions if carry a like
if this was happening in her State she
would say you will have to physically
remove me and I will I will stand in
your way with my own body to stop you
from making this arrest she would do it
she's great man yeah yeah when I was
with her in Phoenix I remember thinking
as I was talking to her like this lady
is actual counterculture you know this
this mom in her nice dress like that's
Counter Culture because she was badass
and she met you could tell everything
she says she means that stuff you spent
a lot of time with her did you interview
her uh no it wasn't a lot of time but it
was well I guess it was a few days of
being court with her and then I
interviewed her uh individually like uh
elsewhere and yeah I thought she was
incredible incredible dude she's she's
uh she's one of the most interesting and
most effective potential like you know
Governors out there when it comes to how
she can handle the media there's yeah
probably no one better than her I agree
and with everything that happened with
the election with the misprinted ballots
and all of that stuff and the ongoing
lawsuits we'll see where it ends up but
after seeing everything that's happened
so far
and and this conversation we're having
right now
I actually think
if Donald Trump said she's going to be
the VP I'd say absolutely 100 yeah oh
for sure absolutely yeah before I was
worried like well she look you look she
worked in media then she ran for office
for I think the first time right I think
so and then she doesn't get the office
so what's the political experience of
doing it now at this point I'm kind of
like I don't care about I want the
opposite of political experience I want
the media experience and I want the
tenacity and the the the The Bravery so
when I wrote that story and I'm sitting
in court I think it was the first day
for her trial and I'm sitting next to
this guy end up ragging at the end of
that story the corporate NBC type guy
who's just blatantly misinterpreting the
reality around him she walks in sees him
immediately and looks at him and goes oh
this guy writes fantasy yes it was
amazing that's remarkable yeah yeah
she's incredible I wonder if some people
have speculated it might be Carrie Lake
for for VP would make sense I I think
that would make sense uh or Vivek
ramaswami at this point he is that
thrilling me because the same thing he's
being vocal and great people people are
smart yeah people are for some reason
questioning him I mean I guess question
everyone that's great but uh he's he's
been nailing every every time he opens
his mouth he's he's incredibly
intelligent he's incredibly successful
he's he's so motion oriented I like that
right one of the best assets that GOP
has right now he's not going to be
president with all due respect but what
he's doing with the conversation is he's
bringing up ESG and the garbage which
needs to happen and again it's being
brought to the front and center he's
really gonna Donald Trump will I think
right now based on all the factors which
is going to change in a year and a half
but if the election was held today I
think Donald Trump would win but the
conversation and the priorities of that
Administration would be shifted by the
victim you already see it being shifted
Vivek it was explicit when he came on
IRL when we were in um at sea at a
turning point that we what we need to do
is reposition our assets our our
investment assets onto a different index
that's not ESG sensitive so put it in
local just different indexes create and
use different indexes and it's the same
thing that uh that Biden just vetoed is
this bill to get ESG out of our
investments because they're not
profitable necessarily they go for like
social crap over profit yeah and it's
the same thing that DeSantis is refusing
to allow in his State and there's a
coalition of other states that are
refusing ESG West Virginia yep and
Virginia West Virginia was doing it I
think first thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time